et maintenant et maintenant
voici clélia ventura
bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir elia 23 dont vous êtes
la fille de lino ventura et vous publié
chez robert laffont un livre qui
s'appelle lino tout simplement
voilà lino tout simplement souvenirs
d'enfance et recettes de famille alors
c'est à la fois une lettre à votre père
lino ventura pour lui dire qu'il vous
manque et puis qu'il vous manque lui sa
cuisine vous dites peu de souvenirs
d'avec mon père qui n'est pas une vague
odeur de persillade d'huile d'olive et
de tomates fraîches
c'est vrai c'est c'était tout pas pas ça
alors à vous parler de votre père vous
parlez de vous parler de votre grand
mère grand mère ça se dit nona en
italien non non non non elle s'appelle
oui ça mais vous l'appelez nona alors
avec elle lui
lino parlait toujours italien est avec
vous jamais en fait n'ont jamais ça
c'est une chose que j'ai jamais compris
mais peut-être que j'ai un peu analysé
c'est à dire que il voulait vraiment lui
qui avait tellement souffert de
l'intégration je pensais il voulait que
nous on soit vraiment intégré donc une
panne italien ouais un peu comme un peu
comme la maire de vence d'enracinement
c'est marrant cette volonté comme ça
d'intégration c'est moins le cas
maintenant
alors elle avait salon anga l7 nona que
comment elle faisait buckingham le
palais de buckingham
elle c'est lé palais des boues jindam
voilà alors c'était oui évidemment
illégal j'espère du film de reagan this
decade gester alors était très
possessive 1 et chaque fois que votre
père lino ventura partait faire un film
de gangsters
elle a éliminé ne suis pas une crise une
maladie très grave quoi ah oui c'était
toujours terriblement pathétique c'est
la commedia dell'arte à la maison
soit ça à l'aide d'un simple migraine à
la crise cardiaque et c'était toujours
quelque chose de terrible parce que papa
y croyez vraiment à les deux trucs
qu'elle supportait pas donc c'était
quand il faisait des films de gangsters
et puis quand il prenait l'avion aussi
un art innocent supportait pas alors
elle était d'une possibilité je dirais
naturel quand on connaît ses origines
parmesane et puis aussi le fait que son
mari donc le père de lino les ai
abandonnés très jeune oui c'est vrai que
ça a été une épreuve très très difficile
et papa l'a très mal vécu
enfin il ne m'en a jamais parlé mais je
crois qu'ils en avions dû beaucoup
beaucoup à cet homme est en fait il est
arrivé en france à 7 ans avec sa mère et
à il a commencé à travailler à cet
incident les sept accidents de three
porter à 9 ans et comme la police
française comme il n'avait pas de
papiers l'accompagnèrent en italie et là
il a été levé par clélia ouais alors de
ces épreuves
lino ventura tirera sa morale et deux
maîtres mots qui sont dignité et respect
alors il était incroyable c'est lino
ventura parce qu'il était comme ça quoi
c'est à dire que par exemple j'ai la
cuisine on va en parler
il n'essaie jamais une cuisine salle
quoi il nettoyait la cuisine quand il
avait fini vous continuez dans un hôtel
il nettoyait la baignoire avant de
partir complètement des principes qu'ils
avaient
le jamais il en rien dérogé à cette
règle là alors vous raconter tous ses
traits c'est très intéressant parce que
c'est vu vraiment de l'oeil delà de la
petite fille quoi donc par exemple
raconterez quand vous habitiez au parc
de montretout ce que vous appelez la
salle des tortures ça que tous les gens
qui venaient présenter des scripts à
lino ventura est passé dans ce bureau et
ils discutent et où il posait des
questions c'est insupportable pour les
scénarii saumon les réalisateurs les
producteurs ppi page man 2 pourquoi il
dit ça non mais je comprends pas parce
que norbert oui mais pourquoi il dit ça
parce que moi dans ma petite tête de
parmesan fond je comprenne
voilà alors les discuter tout mais quand
il avait une fois qu'ils avaient accepté
quand il commençait à tourner après il y
faisait plus rien d'ailleurs tout le
monde avait hâte que ça tourne
il a été discuté oui mais c'est vrai
puisque vous dites s'explique très très
bien le personnage en vous raconter les
dégeler avec demandant cette dans cette
maison alors vous vous étiez obligés de
faire tout paris en mobylette pour aller
chercher les ingrédients à vouvry pour
aller chercher jambon là le pain là
enfin bon tout était la viande railleur
c'était c'était un terrible et alors ils
recevaient beaucoup de gens et un soir
vous surprenez discussions entre autres
jacques brel et votre père vous êtes là
peut être un petit peu caché et brel dit
à votre père en fin de compte c'est quoi
une femme pour toi et lino répond c'est
un homme qui pleure de temps en temps
oui et ça ça m'a beaucoup marqué moi ça
m'a en tant que femme dit ban d'accord
alors n'a le droit de pleurer c'est vrai
qu'on a alors vous raconter les vacances
au cap ferret dans cette maison grappe
d'or la pétanque idée très mauvais
joueur on l'a un peu comme ça je vais
lui montrer qui c'est raoul aux quatre
coins de paris qu' on va le retrouver et
à rieti boussaton puisque et puis alors
les vacances dans la maison d'anjou
parce que pendant la guerre ce que je
savais pas c'est que votre père est
obligé de se cacher parce qu'ils étaient
italiens donc évidemment il était moins
cher qu'ailleurs
ouais est-ce qu il était recherché par
la police française il était recherché
par les allemands il était recherché par
les italiens parce qu'ils n'étaient
déserteurs
il a fait tout un périple pour finir à
barra c'est parce qu'il faudra c'est en
joue donc c'est là et après la guerre
était là bas il a racheté la maison ils
ont arrangé et dont vous raconter les
vacances d'été là-bas visite c'était
très difficile d'éviter la cuisine parce
que le matin quand on se lever pour
aller à la piscine fallait éviter la
cuisine parce que lui c'est déjà
installés et réquisitionné toute la
famille pour faire les pour faire des
plats quoi un petit peu mais même s'ils
n'y ont réquisitionné pas si vous voulez
on était de toute façon réveillé par le
bruit du couteau forcément arriver
devant la grande épreuve du vin le vin
était sa vie en carafe de 6 litres
j'ai espèces d'examen de passage parce
qu'il fallait être capable de tenir la
carafe de 6 litres à un bout de bras oui
et puis je peux vous dire que c'était
pas évident parce que vous les têtes que
j'ai vu une femme lene 18 personnes ce
n'est pas évident vous regrettez de ne
pas le voir plus parler énormément en
tant que femme c'était c'était difficile
de lui parler parce que c'était un
silencieux
oui c'était quelqu'un sais pas c'était
pas quelqu'un d'un abord facile mais
comme tous les pères je crois voulu
parler ce soir